bienvenidos a esta edición especial de
reporteros e france24 hoy con hermina
fernández como invitada ya que ella
realizó la historia que vamos a ver a
continuación que tiene lugar en el delta
del orinoco en venezuela que alberga a
los waraos la segunda población indígena
más importante del país hace 15 años un
grupo de médicos visitó a san francisco
de guayos una de las aldeas indígenas de
esta zona y descubrieron que muchos
habitantes tenían vih de un tipo tan
letal que mata a las personas en menos
de 5 años los indígenas que encontraban
este virus no sólo lidian con la
enfermedad sino que también tienen que
tener tienen que lidiar con las
problemas de alimentación a falta acceso
a los medicamentos y también a la salud
en la actualidad no se han hecho pruebas
para detectar nuevos contagios sin
embargo se conoce que aún hay centenares
indígenas con este virus y otras decenas
han muerto termina fernández se viajó a
estas comunidades del delta del orinoco
junto al camarógrafo omar garcía para
conocer el estado actual en el que se
encuentran los waraos herminia pues un
gusto tenerla aquí en su propio programa
como invitada usted que realizó este
reportaje le pregunto lo más complicado
para esta comunidad indígena
que está muriendo por sida si raúl lo
principal es que ellos están sufriendo
la misma crisis que tiene venezuela sin
embargo para ellos es más complicado
porque viven muy alejados el principal
problema es que no hay transporte y la
gasolina es muy costosa está ya
prácticamente dolarizada ellos tienen
que usar sus curiaras hechas por ellos
mismos para trasladarse a las ciudades
más cercanas y pueden tardar hasta siete
días lo hacen salen de allí para buscar
medicamentos para buscar alimentos
porque no los tienen de sus propias
aldeas pero estas personas también los
indígenas sufren en sus comunidades de
falta de agua falta de electricidad
falta de medicamentos falta de acceso a
la salud y todo esto hace que también
tengan o sufran de otras enfermedades
que no pueden ser atendidas además del
vih y a esto le sumamos que hay una alta
tasa de desnutrición
herminia con este panorama tan
complicado le pregunté el sentimiento
generalizado entre esa población
indígena de saber que van a morir por
sida
si raúl aquí pareciera que ellos todavía
no han entendido el virus o lo que
significa el virus después de 15 años
que fue descubierto en estas aldeas
ellos no se toman sus tratamientos el
que se lo el que se lo toma lo abandona
cuando se siente mejor y hay otros
incluso que acuden son más curanderos
que son como los chamanes típicos de
estas comunidades indígenas acá lo que
pasa también es que no hay un
seguimiento de parte del gobierno
digamos en cuanto a los tratamientos y
tampoco en cuanto a hacer pruebas para
ver cómo va el número de contagios de
los indígenas todo este cóctel pareciera
indicar que el futuro de estas
comunidades indígenas del delta del
orinoco están en peligro y herminia sin
más preámbulos pasamos entonces a ver
este reportaje que usted ha realizado
[Música]
entre las viviendas artesanales de las
comunidades indígenas del delta del
orinoco en venezuela se mueve una
epidemia la del vih/sida rafael pequeño
es enfermero y líder del pueblo de san
francisco de guayos una de las aldeas
donde la cruz roja venezolana detectó al
virus por primera vez en el 2007 él
conoce en detalle cada caso
este paciente siempre recupera
y luego otra vez recae
me imaginé también por falta como dice
un buen
alimentación porque eso totalmente
hoy visita a eduardo un joven que
contrajo el virus cuando tenía 18 años
actualmente tiene 30 ha bajado de peso
presenta diarreas constantes y
afecciones en los huesos su esposa
alexia de 23 le trata sus dolencias con
medicina tradicional
con un tenemos sueldo al comprar
medicamente eduardo bajo el choque el
dolor dice que está tomando su
tratamiento para controlar el virus pero
que no cuenta con medicinas para los
efectos adversos porque no las hay
lo remedio aquí uno va pal hospital hay
remedio pero ahorita
edificio
por qué
la gobernadora que tuve y ver en la
habana era bastante difícil que no manda
mucho para que a veces manda seis meses
o si no un año también reconoce que
parte de su problema es la mala
alimentación por falta de recursos para
una dieta balanceada
aquí nosotros estamos día
esperando un nuevo seis meses siete
meses
siete meses esperando la comida y
de dónde vamos
esperando comida no no tenemos que estar
esperando que nosotros tenemos que estar
para uno comer
para llegar a san francisco de guayos se
necesita tiempo disposición contactos y
dinero no es común que estas poblaciones
tan lejanas que habitan en áreas de
difícil acceso estén expuestas al vih
arelis martínez de la congregación de
las hermanas terciarias capuchinas
comenta que la pobreza ha sido la
principal causa
muchos salen del pueblo a buscar insumos
en un basurero ubicado en puerto ordaz a
siete días en curiara y se contagian
siempre es cada tres meses se atendrá en
una bolsa de comida con unos artículos
que son pocos comes una semana y
el resto del mes y siguientes a pasar
hambre según las religiosas quienes
viven con el virus no están siendo bien
atendidos por las autoridades sanitarias
del país
nuestro gobierno aquí en el delta
manda
desde que yo estoy aquí yo sé que ha
mandado una cajita de no sé qué una
cajita de no sé cuánto dónde se atienden
123 comunidades no se sabe cuál fue el
primer caso registrado pero quince años
después el virus siguen guayos y sus
poblaciones aledañas sin control sin
supervisión y sin ayuda se ha dado un
tratamiento del asunto pero no en la
medida que se requiere o sea no ha
habido erradicación del virus en en san
francisco de guano
[Música]
aunque en san francisco de guayos se
descubrieron los cinco primeros casos
del virus éste ha tenido un gran impacto
en otras aldeas más pequeñas como la de
job uri
rafael visita este día a algunos de sus
pacientes en yogures donde ha habido más
contagios y muertos hace una década se
hicieron pruebas en esta comunidad en
una casa así y en otra no todos los
tests ya dos dieron positivo
y he tratamiento constantemente hijos
billetes de agua y tratamiento bien
frei de 16 años ha parado su tratamiento
y rafael debe averiguar la razón la
respuesta es que su padre le ordenó no
tomarlo más
al principio con el tratamiento me
sentía bien
pero ahora que volví a dejarlo volví a
recaer me siento mal mi papá me dijo que
ya no fuera a buscar más tratamiento
porque me sentía mejor
este joven se contagió a los 14 años en
un viaje al basurero es un secreto a
voces que algunos indígenas cuando salen
de la comunidad recurren al trabajo
sexual como fuente de ingresos
cuando se sienten mal los habitantes de
yogures prefieren acudir a este chamán
para calmar las dolencias sin embargo la
tragedia también tocó la casa del
curandero
para hoy de mis hijos fallecieron dos
por la enfermedad
uno de ellos se llamaba marcelo
y tenía 28 años cuando falleció
mayer
evelio de 30 años conoció su estado de
vih positivo cuando tenía 20 está en el
conducto sembrando como el tubérculo que
comen los cuadrados hoy se siente bien
para trabajar pero no todos los días son
así cuando me siento bien me animo a
salir a trabajar y cuando me siento mal
tania fiebre y diarrea ya no salgo nos
muestra las tumbas de su tío y de su
hermano ambos vivieron por sida tiene
miedo de morir
es lamentable que haya contraído el
virus
deseo seguir sano
y tenéis larga vida pero siento miedo
el vih que se ha encontrado en las
comunidades de los caños del delta son
de un subtipo b y de un subtipo de
alcance tan letal que se convierte en la
etapa más avanzada de la enfermedad en
menos de cinco años
silvia vélez monja y enfermera de la
congregación en san francisco de guayos
es quien lleva por escrito el récord de
los pacientes con tratamiento son 23 en
total los registrados una cifra distante
de lo que puede ser la realidad
los casos que van llegando al hospital
nosotros le hacemos la prueba de esa
prueba rápida sí y bueno y le iniciamos
el tratamiento pero entonces son casos
que ya llegan ya muy deteriorado ya la
gente llega mal entonces nos dice este
es un caso positivo eso lo hacen las
hemos la prueba el precisos
para y libia en la promiscuidad es el
principal factor que incide en el
aumento de casos ya que en la cultura
warao la homosexualidad y bisexualidad
están socialmente aceptadas así como la
integración a las familias de la tira
ruina que significa mujer con pene y que
es como una segunda esposa
ellos no que no fueron muy conscientes
como en eso de que era había b y h
como si no lo queremos ser e irse no lo
asimilaron muchos pensaron que viajen
del vih eso no era osea eso no era de
matar a la gente sino una cosa normal
porque miras cualquier cantidad de gente
que se contagió nunca creyó que tenía
vih
pero los miembros de estas comunidades
con vih como el resto de los que habitan
en las aldeas warao sufren otros males
que empeoran su calidad de vida no hay
luz desde hace 8 años tampoco agua
potable conseguir alimentos es otra
calamidad y carecen de un sistema de
salud
rafael dejo una emergencia para ir a
buscar la bolsa de comida que el
gobierno da a la población a bajo precio
es un evento esporádico y no puede
perder la oportunidad
hace cuatro meses nos llegó la comida
para vender y ante el hito que llegaron
nuevamente llegar que es para pasar me
imagino como cuatro o cinco meses más
para volver llegar a la cuerda la comida
de nuestra comunidad
yo ni se avería tiene una hermana que
convive con vih y por ahora está bien de
salud pero aclara que el mal en general
de su familia no es el virus sino la
alimentación siente que su etnia está
abandonada
quisiéramos estar bien pero nadie nos
ayuda
damián también cansado de la mala
alimentación no ha querido seguir
esperando más por la comida que envía el
gobierno ha decidido sembrar para no
pasar hambre
por qué no
aquí lo contamos
como con las comidas
las opciones de alimentación son
limitadas
no contamos por ejemplo el derecho de la
alimentación será por lo lejos que el
gobierno
esta atención bella aquí por ejemplo
comemos okubo en la mañana al mediodía y
en la tarde
el enfermero warao vuelve a sus
actividades en el hospital la paciente
con un feto muerto en su vientre desde
hace tres días ya no soporta el dolor la
ambulancia se pidió 24 horas antes y
tengo miedo porque está trancado
porque en mi anterior parto el niño vino
de pie la rae en la misma sala se
encuentra un niño que ha caído de un
árbol no hay rayos x- ni medicamentos
para atenderlo
al tenerlo paciente así guiada
no le digo a los que no tengan al
alcance conoce
el centro de salud inaugurado en 2010
luce como un hospital fantasma en este
momento no hay médicos hasta nuevo aviso
rafael muestra cada espacio en desuso en
la inauguración sí un poquito aparato
haciendo su 1 simulacro pero después el
día después que terminó la inauguración
lleva ahora alguno aparato si había aquí
si había en cada habitación había uno
aire jet o
pero y ese día estaba dañando se dañó a
dieta y ahorita no como dice maya le
está parando
en la farmacia no hay medicamentos
básicos pero si hay antirretrovirales
para el vih que son enviados por el
gobierno de vez en cuando estos están
vencidos los pacientes no los van a
retirar
rafael / haber otra paciente que acaba
de llegar desde una comunidad lejana y
tuvo un aborto no hay material para él
curetaje la bañan le consiguen ropa y la
envían de vuelta a su casa sin haber
recetado ningún antibiótico
algunos cuadrados que no conocen a la
mujer se acercan a ver cómo está la
paciente van a dar apoyo a la
desconocida porque comprenden que la
situación sanitaria es compleja
tenemos que comprarlo
y
pero rafael insiste que entre todas las
carencias de salud la más grave es no
tener lo básico para mantener el vih
bajo control para que nosotros podamos
trabajar con otros hermanos para
detectar
enfermedades que el virus del vih
según el informe de monitoreo global de
sida del año 2020 la prevalencia del vih
en la población general es de 0.53 por
ciento y hasta hace unos pocos años en
la etnia warao era de 92 por ciento en
la actualidad no existen datos precisos
de cuántas personas pueden tener la
enfermedad ni cuántos han muerto por el
virus sin mediciones ni controles la
comunidad ha entrado en un ciclo
imposible de detener
hay personas que lo portan y no quieren
aceptar esa realidad y se entrega para
morir o sea me pasan casos de personas
por la mente que están en esa situación
algunos habitantes de guayos suponen que
los casos están controlados en su aldea
el año pasado
me dijeron que salieron bien la gente de
aquí de esta comunidad pero de las otras
comunidades y se abrieron un poco más
aunque salieron cuatro alrededores de la
parroquia
[Música]
y así sucede hoy que es día de
celebración vive en la vida como si no
hubiera mañana y sin pensar en las
consecuencias
siempre y cuando tenga algo siempre
comparte con los demás
con sus amigos es un lugar
a falta de jornadas de detección el
contagio de vih sigue expandiéndose
entre los waraos una delgada línea es la
división entre vivir y morir el virus
llegó para quedarse es el nuevo ciclo de
vida de esta comunidad indígena
[Música]
pues termina realmente complicado todo
el tema de salud que vive esta comunidad
indígena de los waraos en venezuela
gracias igual también por supuesto por
el reportaje ustedes continúen con
nosotros hay mucho más para ver en
frases de pasto
[Música]